[Music]
i want to start by saying congrats on
the movie i had a strong emotional
reaction to it
to penguin bloom and i really enjoyed
the film
uh i just wanted to start with that and
that's all i have have a great day
thank you very much lovely
can you sort of talk about what the film
is about uh well the film
is based on a true story uh of an
australian woman who was on holiday
with her family and she had an accident
in thailand which
broke her back and she resulted in being
in a wheelchair she was a
paraplegic and she
came back to australia was unable to
walk in a wheelchair
um and was not in a great place as you
can imagine
uh as she was drifting away from her
family and friends and kind of isolating
herself
in a deep depression and one of her kids
brings home
a little bird that they found on the
road that had fallen from
a tree and they kind of form this
friendship
and i guess it's it's through that
friendship that
sam bloom uh the character uh her life
shifts a little bit and um you know she
gets
she she finds hope and the family comes
together and there's some
uh you know there's there's a reasonably
happy ending i guess that's the there's
the story in a in a nutshell in an egg
shell
when you were given the script and you
and you're looking at it and you guys
are having conversations about
doing it yeah at what point are you like
can we actually make this movie because
of the bird yeah i mean there's a lot of
i mean in in some ways we had to be
careful that
you know you've got to talk about the
bird non-stop in prep and
make sure you've got all bases covered
and trying to work out how we're
actually going to do it
but at the same time you don't want the
bird to that you know all the focus to
go on the bird because it's a much
bigger story you know than than just the
bird
but we we found a trainer very early on
uh a guy called paul mander who is not
really a film guy like he's not like a
normal
animal wrangler but he's sort of a bird
whisperer
and we went and visited him he lived up
in the
um up in queensland in australia
and we just asked all these questions
like if i wanted a bird if i wanted a
magpie
to fly in the door and land on the table
and in a spot like where would put an x
could you do that and you'd be like yeah
we could do that and
if you wanted a bird to come in and i
don't know pull a tea bag out of a cup
could you do that yeah
that's no problem and he was so relaxed
about it it sort of gave us confidence
and
and in a funny way that's the only way
you can move forward with
a project like this like you have to
have confidence that it's going to work
and look you know to talk about the bird
generally it did like it it didn't
always
you know firstly we never wanted to
treat penguin
as a pet uh or as a as a tame bird like
it's a wild bird that sort of
you know in a way in in the way we
approached it it chose to live with the
family as opposed to them
keeping it and it was free to come and
go
in real life and was in the film um
so we really wanted the bird to be a
wild bird
that we could control a little bit and
sometimes it did sometimes that you know
it kind of
did everything we wanted in one take and
other times you'd be there for an hour
trying to get it to do something and try
you know
piecing it together later in the edit
and other times and i said generally
penguin would do something that only a
bird would do
and then you kind of you've got to lean
to it you've really got to accept that
and
embrace that and the story then becomes
around what penguin's doing not what we
initially expected it to do and you know
that's the film was about
the power of nature and the healing
power of nature and we learned a lot of
sometimes hard lessons about working
with nature um
but yeah ultimately it's uh you know it
worked yeah
well when you are filming a movie where
you have a lot of key
scenes with naomi and penguin or penguin
and one of the kids are you using more
cameras than maybe you would normally be
using
to have a wider lens in case the bird
does something a little
different like how are you shooting
these sequences
um no generally it was it was one camera
and
even when i say that i'll go wow that's
a crazy decision why do we do that
but in in a way like a lot of those
scenes you just you wanted to minimize
uh distraction really because a bird can
just you know they
they they get distracted by everything
that's in and around them
um but we yeah we were just able to you
know with with coverage i guess
and and sort of trying to get the bird
to do the same thing
in a slightly different way each time um
we were able to piece it
together um
and and an incredible luck you know but
sometimes you know some of those
sequences in the film that looks simple
we may have been
filming you know trying to get that shot
for an hour or two hours or something
like that or within you know within the
time frame that we could barely you know
just to the point where like well we
could spend another two hours and not
get anything so
it was it was always a time balance you
know it's it's kids and animals
well that's the other thing is that your
film is loaded with kids
and uh an animal that is required to do
things and
certain i mean it's a it's a daunting uh
it was i can only imagine it was a
daunting shoot
yeah although i mean i will say that
sometimes penguin
the bird was sometimes easier to wrangle
than those three boys when they're in
the room together
and if you put three boys and a bird in
there you may as well have four birds
like they're
the same thing but i i guess it's just i
don't know my approach and
and what i realized is that you really
with kids and animals
you can only you can only guide and
nudge you can never
you can't go in with expectations that
you're going to hit these things
you know in the exact way you have to
sort of
embrace what they're giving you um
and i i love working that way like and
and in a funny way
working with penguin and working with
those young kids but
it was the same approach you you set the
parameters and you know what the scene's
got to be about
and then you sit back and cross your
fingers and hope that
that you know the way you've designed it
um is is going to work and
and more often than not it did and
occasionally it didn't
and and well and very
and occasionally and sorry more often
than not you would get something that
was even
more beautiful than you expected um so i
was always open to it i was always open
to whatever's going to happen
particularly when you've got a bird in
the frame
you really can't control it i'm always
fascinated by
the opening shot of the movie and the
closing shot of the movie
how much time did you spend like or how
much time do you spend
thinking about what's that first shot
gonna be what's that last shot gonna be
you know i had pretty clear idea about
what the last shot of the film was going
to be
um and i i guess rather than being that
specific
i'm i guess i'm always interested in
thematically what's bookending a film
like what are the
and and i try and find something that's
cyclic almost so
you sort of in our film you you
absolutely
be you end where you began um
it's a very similar shot but hopefully
you're seeing it in a very different way
now so i like that i like that i like
the idea of bookending and the cyclic
nature of storytelling that you can
you can end where you began but you're
seeing it in a different way because of
what you've learned along the way
completely um i believe that you shot a
lot of the movie from
sam or naomi's perspective like the
camera was always at
her sort of height uh when did you
decide that that's the way you wanted to
shoot it
it's an approach i've had for a long
time in in everything i've made i've
i've always sort of set a height
and it's for many reasons it's partly
for point of view like whose story is it
um it's partly through trying to
reduce the amount of decisions that you
can make on set particularly when you've
got a lot of
things going on like birds and kids and
that's something so if you always know
that the camera is roughly going to be
at a person's height then a certain
person inside a certain character's
height
it sort of eliminates a lot of other
decisions that you're going to make for
that setup
but particularly for sam in this story
um
we realized that you know if if you're a
person in a wheelchair
you see things a bit differently you
know you see people like probably how
you're seeing me
on this screen like it's the roof that's
behind you or
and partic and for our story there's a
bird on the floor so it's the floor so
you're actually seeing
the world a bit differently um and i
thought that was important
um to sort of really you know get the
audience
into a sense of what it's like to be at
that height you know
people in wheelchairs paraplegics
quadriplegics
um they see the world from a different
perspective
and i and it was it was something i was
very keen on
establishing in the film uh talk a
little bit about the editing room
uh i'm always curious about how a film
can be altered
changed in the editing room uh so
i guess how long was your first cut
compared to the finished film
well that's a good question um it's not
like i didn't have a
i didn't have a a cut that was like
three hours long
you know it was probably two hours maybe
or something like that
um and it was just a you know it was a
really enjoyable process in that i love
editing
and i feel like that's where you know
the film is made i'm a
huge believer in that process um and
i guess for us it was you know the film
the story it's very simple it's a simple
story and the book that it's based on is
very simple but there's a poetry and i
guess a lyricism to the
way that that story is told visually uh
and and in the edit it was really about
trying to
it was a trying to find that calibration
between revealing too much and
just enough but not too much uh
particularly in in
the the transformation of sam sam's
character of naomi what's his character
if you you know it's frames here or
there in the end like if you go too
far the story feels like it's it's over
but if you hold it back
it's not moving fast enough so it was a
very delicate balance
um as well as you know trying to
make uh a character in penguin
like and what i really what one of the
things i was drawn to
with this story was having a main
character in the film who didn't speak
um and as a bird and trying to find ways
of
you know without anthropomorphizing the
boot we didn't treat it as a
we didn't really give it human qualities
but how do we understand what a bird is
thinking and how do we understand what a
bird is feeling
uh in these different situations so i
was
finding penguins voice and penguins
character and how
that character as you know an animal and
one that didn't speak
in amongst uh you know a a family and a
bunch
and a bunch of really great actors uh
what did you learn from any friends and
family screenings
that uh impacted the finished film
oh that's a really good question i try
and
whenever i watch the film through
particularly like when you when it's
starting to take shape i just always try
and have someone
someone a fresh pair of eyes in the room
and you find that you watch it through
their eyes
um so there was there was multiple
things i had friends
there were certain scenes or you know
trying to find you know talking about
this calibration
uh there was you know and we were sort
of taking frames off
you know or sort of fine-tuning scenes
and occasionally someone would say like
you should just lose that scene
and i'm never you know i'm not one to
say i can't lose that i can't lose a
frame but
it was actually in trying to you know
find that fine calibration it just
needed to be removed
and i'm always surprised in the edit
suite how
how you know things that you thought
were important aren't
like you can just do without it and and
this and those things that you didn't
think were important actually become
crucial
um and it's it's a process that you know
constantly
bewilders me and excites me and inspires
me yeah i've spoken to a lot of
filmmakers that that also talk about
that you know once you've seen the movie
a thousand times
everything becomes meaningless like you
have to have outside eyes
yeah yeah it's and it's and it's strange
whether that's
you know without with our film we tried
to watch it with a variety of different
people because it is
it is it's you know we wanted to make a
film that's not you know it's not a
family film but it's a film you can take
your family to so you try and watch it
with young people with
old people with people who don't like
birds or you know if you just try and
get it
and and it's and people who don't really
have anything to do with films like
they're not filmmakers
you you just you just want to you know a
normal person's response
and they're obviously the most honest
and the most brutal and kids as well
like i once read that uh you know
that there's no better story editor than
a 10 year old and
and it's the same thing as a in a film
like if they get bored
or something doesn't make sense they'll
just tell you they're not trying to not
trying to
they're not interested in subtext or
character arcs they just want a good
story
a hundred percent uh this is in a very
unusual
uh film and story because you actually
shot at the real house that the blooms
live
at and your onset photographer
was the person the husband you know
and it's like everyone the whole family
was basically there and involved
which has to be a little weird as a
filmmaker to be
at their house and have them around all
the time
what was that like well it's it wasn't
weird for me because it just made sense
like that
and you've seen the film it's a very
specific house and you can do certain
things on that house like you can stand
on the roof and
and and the view which was important to
the story that you know they live on
this
you know on the edge of the ocean and
you really wanted that
you know for the character we we needed
to find somewhere that not only had all
these other physical features but the
geography
in particular felt like it was taunting
sam from the outside like her old life
was out there constantly
beckoning her to come out um
and i liked the idea of you know it's
it's a very emotional story
and quite raw at times and i just like
that idea that we were shooting it
in the actual environment like if the
walls could talk
you know that that kind of thing it's
almost like the dna of the story was in
the walls of the house that we were
shooting in
you know we're not only making a true
story about a terrible event in
someone's life
but it's actually the husband and wife
and their kids and now their house like
it was a very intrusive process
in many ways uh and we i just wanted to
be as respectful as i could
um as but at the same time you know you
do have to overtake the house like you
just they you know that we had to move
them out and it's a big deal but
um i feel i feel like the film has an
authenticity
um that we couldn't have got if we'd
shot it in another house if that makes
sense like it was
it was you know it's a very special
house and
uh i i was really happy that we could
shoot in there like otherwise it would
have been it would be a very different
film in a very different house it's very
easy
to shoot that house because of the
backdrops that are all around it
everything is just cinematic yeah you
know this story
and i guess that's one of the beautiful
things about the story and it's in its
universality
uh this is a story that could happen to
anyone like
you could have an accident that uh that
renders you
in a wheelchair for the rest of your
life i guess the gift of this story was
uh this story could have happened to
someone who lives in an apartment
um but this story happened to someone
who lived in an incredible
part of the world um and who was whose
life was
in that world like she was so physical
and outdoors
in the lead-up to this accident um
that many times you know it's not not
really in the film but she just wanted
to move like she wanted to get out of
that place because she felt like it was
constantly
teasing her and and taunting her um so
yeah
the the location is a really important
part of
any story but specifically for this
story it's very important
what i mean listen you're this is based
on a true story and you have the real
people around
um but you're also making a movie so
what is it like
obviously you have to i'm assuming you
had to fictionalize at least a few
things in the film
from what really happened but so what is
it like having cameron or sam around
watching you fictionalize it do you know
what i mean
yeah um look sometimes it was really
great it it well often it was to have
sam and ken there for authenticity like
you know and particularly the
you know we wanted to get the
the the wheelchair life very
accurate and all all
um spinal injuries are different and sam
blooms is
is you know as it says in the film it's
from the brass strap down like from the
chest down
she can't move she can't feel anything
so
naomi had to move in certain ways
and couldn't couldn't do could and could
do certain things so it was really great
to have like a you know
like the practical stuff like no you
couldn't do that or you have to hold
yourself here and
and i know for nomi it was very
important to have sam there
for a lot of the emotional work as well
to have her presence there i think was
important for nomi
whereas cam and andy lincoln who plays
cam um andrew didn't need cam around and
i think he didn't like being watched in
like the real
character watching him so i would say
like every actor would would be
different
and i was i was happy for them to oh you
know i wanted my actors
and my cast to feel as support as
possible so what they wanted i wanted
it was a bit of both sure it's uh
what did it mean to you i'm not sure if
you were a fan of walking dead uh but
andrew this is his first project after
rapping on walking dead he and this is
the only thing i think he's done
since rapping on walking dead uh did
that mean anything to you
landing him for this role um
it meant something to me because i love
him as an actor it really meant
something to my
son my teenage son in fact
early on uh when we when we really
started looking for
for an actor to play cam and you know
we're putting lists together and really
thinking who we want to who we want to
play this part
um my son said i usually get andrew
lincoln
and i was like i don't like you know i
was thinking of walking dead and i was
like i don't know if andrew is right but
when we
when we uh ended up sending it to him
because we you know we really looked at
that and thought it was a really great
idea
eventually um he responded so generously
to the script
in fact he had a copy of the book in the
house and when i first
spoke to him he said he was three pages
into the script
and he was like this story's familiar
and he went to his shelf and he'd had
you know penguin bloom um which was a
film a book that he
he and his wife had got and he had read
it to his family and they already loved
so
he had a he had a connection emotional
connection to it very early on
his biggest fear i think um and what you
know it is it's the first thing he's
done since the walking dead
he read a lot of scripts in the meantime
um
he wanted to do something different and
it is a very different role for him
um his biggest concern was really the
accent like could he
could he pull off an australian accent
um and
and could he do that convincingly
knowing that he was going to have
there's going to be a lot of ad living
particularly when you've got kids and uh
kids and animals they're not going to do
it so
and um he he just jumped straight into
it the moment he landed
in australia um or even before he was
working with a dialect coach and
um and i you know it's it's it's an
amazing accent and amazing that he could
just
jump into that and and make it so
perfect but it was an absolute pleasure
and andrew lincoln's one of the sweetest
guys and a beautiful person
and i'm really pleased that he said yes
to her film
totally um did he actually stay
with that accent all the time or was he
yeah
yeah because i've heard that from people
that they just have to stay with that
accent
even when they're not shooting just to
keep it and
not to break it yeah he from the in fact
when i first met andrew in his hotel
room
we went well i went just you know many
when he physically arrived in australia
and he was speaking australian he had
the accent when he when he opened the
door
like he he just stuck with it and i
think it's the only way he can work like
i don't think you can swap between the
two because he's english so he's got an
english accent
most people think he has an american
accent um
and he's very you know he's and i
wouldn't say his method because
it wasn't like he was like can bloom all
the time but i think it was very
important for him that he maintained
that accent
um and he didn't slip away from it and
it was all practice for him like
like every conversation was was
practiced yeah i've spoken to a lot of
people who uh
um who who keep the accent at all times
uh just because they have to you know
and
i'd probably do the same thing but i
don't have that ability um
listen i already uh i'm going to say
that uh our time is up and i just wanted
to say that i
again i really enjoyed this film i'm
very confident it's going to get
released in america because
it's excellent and you have two great
actors
you know uh you know uh championing the
material
and naomi watts what why not i meant two
you know
i'm talking about penguin oh well that
too yeah i guess that's true no but i
mean listen i i'm a
i'm a sucker for for animal movies and
you know
um uh you know i really enjoyed this
film
um so listen um great talking with you
and wish you nothing but the best
and good luck with all the other
interviews thank you so much
and um yeah thanks for your time i'm
glad you liked the film